what's up guys it is the last tip it's
causing my first thing we're here as we
can excited
I'll be sitting there in a second
amazing but you don't think I know what
you've got me baby I know I'm not the
only one over here at the Instagram
lounge and Louis is here how are you you
guys didn't see the podcast we did
together you're gonna have to check it
out I'll put a link in description right
now most important the trophy that you
guys thought into round one
and I want in the juggling
it's our game awards reunion Hey
logging back here sorry are you I was
gonna say we need to go we need a
flashback to our operator hotel room
days remember let me just play it I'm
better one two three
is bleeding subject okay first of all we
quick shape when they did we get like a
little outfit number where your camel
pants to the Q&A
[Music]
[Applause]
so that's it for VidCon 2015 I've been
sleeping all day long I had so much fun
I love seeing you guys man that's up how
does I look exhausted I didn't even go
on party like everybody else did so I
can't even imagine how they're feeling
this Sunday afternoon so I'll see you
guys later and that's it peace is the
ten-day one we're here I feel good how
do you feel all right good